[Music]  are you dating anybody right now um I've  been dating but I'm not I pull back a  little bit  and I'm kind of like in the middle I'm  open to new ideas Real Housewife of New  York City  Bethenny Frankel is moving on from her  bitter divorce I used to really feel so  hopeless and not understand why and now  this is giving this be strong is giving  me an outlet and a reason for it some  place to put my my sadness and some of  my sort of depression and hopelessness  be strong as Bethenny's charity  initiative it's linked with another  organization giving back to women in  need Dress for Success  as for Bethenny's six-year-old daughter  Brynn while she is focused right now on  Christmas this year we actually did the  tree together yeah it's really fun  [Music]  you